today's topic someone sent me these tick
tocks i'm not gonna regret it but it's a
conversation that needs to be started
my son is 11 years old and when he turns
i'm thinking about getting him a
vasectomy now
that's got to be the dumbest [ __ ] i've
heard today and i've heard some pretty
dumb
when you get 14 year olds you're
thinking about getting him a vasectomy
did you raise this kid alone
did you i mean the way she's talking
sounds like it but let's let's hear her
let's hear the reasoning
to other boy moms is this something that
you guys are thinking about
um if not why
any pointers questions concerns that
charmaine had
i have a daughter she's 13 years old but
when she's 14 i'm thinking about getting
an hysterectomy
removing her uterus that's not true that
she's gonna have
and i know it's probably a bad example
because you know vasectomy
are sometimes reversible still
wow you you checked out basically you
didn't know what the main author made
the difference between
wanting a baby and being a parent you
checked the [ __ ] out
you're like i wanna have a baby or a
baby with an accident or whatever
right because you were [ __ ]
delusional your partner [ __ ] off
and you had a baby and you're not a
parent
a parent apparently [ __ ] out of your
mind
and there's a difference between being a
parent and wanting a baby
because when that baby grows up you have
to
parent him or her or they whatever
and then you checked out instead of
doing your parents job let me educate
this little [ __ ]
be like hey listen you need to do this
and that and that and that you check the
[ __ ] out
you actually is lazy i'ma say it
i don't know you but just about what you
said i don't want to have to do it
because i maybe there's something that
you're lazy
you're lazy that's lazy ass
thinking you check the [ __ ] out you said
you know what i'm not going to raise
them i want a baby i don't want to raise
them
man doesn't make any sense i don't have
to deal with
i don't want to have to deal with that
why would i have to deal with that
because you're supposed to be a parent
but no you're just a [ __ ] with a baby
and that's the difference
there are parents and [ __ ] with baby
and when i'm talking about [ __ ] with
baby it's not a feminine thing
woman and a man can be [ __ ] that's
just what happened to me one of them
i can't even believe that you thought of
that that was your thought process
vasectomy sniff nip
makes sense you check the [ __ ] out
that's what happened
you lazy ass baby [ __ ]
that's a good one that's good i think
the last one the last one caught me off
guard sorry
lazy ass baby what lazy ass baby [ __ ]
you know they're going to be in the
comments lazy ass baby [ __ ]
rate it out of 10. you know what i
appreciate she's like hey you know moms
you guys thought about this and if so
what reservations do you have
why don't you want to do it so
women are not thinking about this
it's just you oh by the way dum-dum
maybe you're trolling because no doctor
will allow you to do that to a
14-year-old actually
oh hell no yes no
they strongly advise against it but they
can't do it you lazy ass baby [ __ ] put
your money elsewhere like put him in
through college or some [ __ ]
yeah dum-dum why wouldn't you though is
the expectation of
grandchildren a thing because it's not
for me i don't care if my kids
have kids to come into this world and be
[ __ ] no thank you
no pause pause pause not only your lazy
baby [ __ ]
you lazy ass selfish baby [ __ ]
whoa and you feel entitled about that
bruh i don't want my kids to have
grandchildren
it's not even you know what's worse she
just wanted a baby
if you listen to her words she says
i don't like i don't want my kids to
raise garbage kids
as if she's already assuming that her
children are going to be fuck-ups
which means she thinks she's a fuck-up
well
about that yes
she has to be trolling and good
good job good job for that troll because
you got the reaction
the only thing about tick tock but i
found her account oh she deleted her
account
i can see why but like why why wouldn't
you sterilize
them i mean we realize that
there is a huge problem in our society
but we are not
strong enough to take the actions that
needs to be taken in order to fix the
problem the
audacity of a [ __ ]
please look at me like that
she said we have a problem in this
society
and we don't want to take the steps in
order to raise your goddamn
kids you're not wanting to take the
trips that's what you're doing right now
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
man wow yo let's go then what exactly
are we doing simply just talking about
it are we just like
having a communal like place where we
can go and gripe about it because i
quite frankly don't want to deal with
the problem
i don't want to deal with the griping i
don't want to deal with the
all of it so just i don't know share
share that part with me
i don't know if you can stitch this but
i hope you can okay you didn't want a
kid you wanted you wanted a dog
you wanted a puppy that's what you
wanted you wanted a puppy
so you sterilize the [ __ ] out of it so
it doesn't do more
and you have to you know uh it's gonna
you know it's funny how people that you
know
funny people are the people that really
like animals but they're gonna get it
at the dog from a kennel and they're
gonna you know they're gonna sterilize
the [ __ ]
they're gonna sterilize the [ __ ]
they're gonna be well i don't want that
i'm gonna cut the nails because they
don't destroy my furniture that's what
it is i have a pet
right just for your safety she's she i
find that weird
but okay whatever but you apply that
same logic
to your kids okay
let me ask you you ever come with some
dumb ideas yeah
what do you do when you come with a dumb
idea think about it and then what
throw it in the trash or get a second
opinion
right you won't probably go on you
wouldn't go on tick-tock or instagram
you might go to somebody who opinion you
trust right
if i had an issue concerning my child
and i'm like how do i race them you know
what i would do
go talk to my wife the person i'm
raising the child with
or somebody who knows what they're
talking about i wouldn't go to tick tock
talk about my 15 year old child who can
likely see the video
and say i want him sterilized because i
don't want him raising [ __ ]
kids the level of irresponsibility in
this whole dynamic is
crazy crazy that's how i know this girl
got nobody in her life to talk to
she went to tick tock to talk about
sterilizing her child because if she had
somebody in life someone but like you're
a [ __ ] idiot
probably keep that to yourself
i feel bad for a kid that's all i'm
gonna say
step fully so focus on instead of being
so focused on whether or not he's gonna
raise a sick child
just do your best to raise a good child
maybe that should be where your energy
is
instead of coming up with stupid ideas
but hey it seems like you've already
quit
seems like you've already given up like
roots oh you checked out so you packed
your bags
you went to the reception and you said
you know what i'm checking out on that
kid
you're the room of your keys you're the
key to your room
she got me [ __ ] up that's why
[ __ ] goddamn lazy baby [ __ ]
grocery store express she didn't even go
to the cashier she went straight to the
machine
extra fast she checked out quick quick
are we done
or is we finished i said i was about to
say
hey listen this moment quit she even put
her two weeks notice
that is one hell of a way to quit
[Music]
[Applause]
a